Side pressure is the most confusing and misunderstood thing in arm wrestling.
Even guys who have been doing that for I don't know how many years explain it in a way that actually creates more confusion.
From statements that there is no such thing as a side pressure movement, that everything is side pressure, or there is no side pressure muscle, there is no side pressure movement, there is only supination or pronation.
And at some point, everyone is right and wrong.
It's right if we take their understanding of side pressure, but to understand their perspective, you need to understand what side pressure is and then put their filter on.
And it's really simple.
It's really simple.
I'm going to explain what side pressure really is, and at the end, I'm going to show you my exercises, or simple exercises, for how to do it.
First, we need to understand, from an anatomical point of view, what side pressure is, because that's really all that matters.
When you're going to understand this, all this misunderstanding will be gone.
There are people who say it's going to come with time.
You don't have to train it.
Crazy things have been said about side pressure.
But let's focus on our anatomy, okay?
So this is a forearm.
And everything that passes through this joint and everything that stabilizes my forearm
from going outside the line of my shoulder.
So in literature, it's called valgus, okay?
So everything that prevents this is side pressure.
I'm not talking about the ability to do something.
I'm talking about an anatomical way to understand it.
So everything that allows you to move in this direction, right, has to pass through this joint.
So, for example,
the fingertip flexor muscle ends up here.
So it does not contribute to side pressure, but another finger flexor, flexor digitorum superficialis, passes this joint. So one of the finger flexor muscles is actually a side pressure muscle.
Okay?
So we have our fingers. What else passes through the joint?
Wrist flexor.
Radial flexor, flexor carpi radialis, ulnar flexor of the wrist. Okay, so we have this, we have this. So it's already three muscles that pass through the hand, through the joint, and the whole forearm. Okay, we have a muscle that, I mean, not all of us have this muscle, because about twenty percent of people don't have this muscle. It's
palmaris longus. This is the Latin name for this one, and actually, this is something that helps you flex your wrist, but it's not really important, as you see, because not all people even have this muscle. But this is the fourth one. One, two, three, four, yeah. Okay, and pronator teres. So
these are our muscles that pass through this joint and prevent valgus, okay? There is a function of biceps and brachioradialis, obviously, but it's way lower because they stabilize the joint at a different angle. So this is what I will refer to as side pressure, okay? So we have our muscles. As you see, most of them are coming through from the hand.
Okay, so if you're losing your fingers, you're losing a side pressure component. You're losing your wrist, you're losing a side pressure component. You're losing your pronation, then you are on a ligament, UCL, ulnar collateral ligament. And this position is when your injury happens, because if there is no muscle
to cover, to take the tension and fight this force that is forcing you to go outside, there's only the ligament that stays in place, preventing your arm from going out of your joint.
And this is where these injuries are actually happening.
So the ligament is the last and only line of defense when you are in such a position, right?
Center position.
And there are some people who are pulling like that, right?
Well, they still use pronation, but you would have to lose pronation completely.
You would have to pull this way, this way.
So you should do something like that.
But in general, do not rely on your ligament.
Maybe you have ultra-strong ligaments, but yeah, there is no point.
I mean,
I don't think we should train it.
We should train only to prevent injury, but not to use this position in a real fight.
So we have the full picture of what side pressure anatomy looks like.
And now let's think about how we apply it.
So there are people who say you go sideways.
I don't really believe that there is anyone who goes sideways on the table like that. I don't know if you know anyone, just tell me, because from what I understand, I'm going to take a bolt so it's going to be easier to understand for you. Side pressure is all through the pronation chain, or through the outside chain. So
pronation, first radial flexor, brachioradialis, biceps.
We are in this position and we are pulling, but not here, but there.
So the vector goes pretty much to our shoulder.
And you don't go like that.
It's pulling this vector.
So I call it outside-style pronation, which engages back pressure muscles, so biceps, brachialis, brachioradialis, pronator teres, most of it, and the first wrist flexor, obviously the other muscles.
And there is inside side pressure, which you also do not apply this way.
With a little bit of supination, and that's mostly the ulnar flexor of your wrist.
This is why you should train your side pressure with emphasis on one of these vectors, because you will never have a situation where you go sideways this way, because this is actually
you stay with your flexors, but you use way less muscle than you potentially can to make the side pressure move, okay?
Because if I'm going like that, I'm using more muscle.
If I'm going like that, I'm using more muscle.
You don't want to train it like that because you do not apply it like that.
If you're a hooker, presser, you do apply it this way, okay?
And if you are outside style, you do apply it through pronation.
Okay, so you know now what side pressure really is from an anatomical point of view.
So how do you train it?
Wrist flexion, fingers, pronation, supination.
This is how we train it because these are the muscles that you actually
use for your side pressure. So whenever you do any kind of curl, any kind of pronation lift, whatever you do that targets these muscles, you train your side pressure. I'm going to show you an exercise that I've been doing for a while that is, in my opinion, the most isolated way to do the full side pressure chain,
outside side pressure for top roll.
So as you see, I do not pull it this way because, yeah, you know why.
I'm going at about forty-five degrees, and the line is going right somewhere here, okay?
I will do it isometrically.
So I just pull as hard as I can, and that's it, okay?
And in this situation, in this exercise,
through my thumb to my radial flexor, also some muscles that are responsible for wrist stabilization, so abductor, brachioradialis, biceps, pronator teres, all of them work together, giving me this side pressure movement. And of course, if I position myself like that, it can make the impression that I go
sideways. But every time you really execute your side pressure move, it's through something. So even if I, okay, I go pretty sideways now, still, even if I go this direction, I engage it through this chain. So these muscles are contracted one hundred percent, and that's the idea of side pressure, that it's a compound move.
And it uses pretty much everything you do for your style.
I'm going to show you a second exercise for inside-style side pressure.
Something like that.
Okay.
So I have
here my multi-spinner, and again I have my fingers engaged, okay? I go down, and my ulnar flexor is working the most. I add to it a little bit of triceps, a little bit, you know, of shoulder, but in general, you get what I mean, right?
This is a compound move, and I just pull, okay?
And I feel those muscles contracted right into this place.
Yeah.
So, well, I train isometrically.
You don't have to. You can do it however you like, but that's the idea.
This is the way you're going to hit your side pressure muscles, depending on whether you go outside or inside.
If you want to do it with wrist range, well, you can, but I really think that aside from a position that you don't really want to be in, but it's really hard, maybe here someone is top rolling you, you are holding like that. This is not what you really want to do, but maybe in this situation you will benefit from wrist range, because
but still, you want to engage your pronation as much as you can.
So I think this is the right way to approach side pressure training.
And even if you're not going to use these exercises, I hope you will finally understand what side pressure is and that there are side pressure muscles that you can train, that it does not come with time, and the whole misunderstanding of side pressure will be gone.
Bye.